you
hello everybody welcome to Wednesday hey
I'm drew my Ben hi there
it is Wednesday isn't it's Wednesday my
dude it is indeed Persia is not feeling
well so I am taking over the stream with
Ben today and we're gonna be playing
hold on so let me check my notes really
quick you can't you can't do a
transition as I could in the office I
feel like reach over we're playing call
of duty because the season three passes
out so we're just gonna hop it in play
apologies up front
I haven't played much call duty since
launch so forgive me big seems so we're
all just gonna kind of go on a wonderful
admission where you have fun time so
yeah here we go
battle pass up front it gives me Alex
he's one of the characters from the
campaign also gives me this dude who I
think you you haven't it's just like a
custom skin for him those hot tattoos
are looking good yeah yeah and then yeah
just some you know call a duty stuff got
my my call duty points got your guns
they use your gun books your cod bucks
I'm 11 minutes out from finishing my my
update I'll be joining you shortly
fantastic yeah Ben's gonna join me
afterwards and yeah I think we're just
gonna hop in and play here I hope get
the new map I don't know I'm sorry on
the wards on tab so they should have a
if this is how they used to season three
mosh pit probably that one yeah that's
you gotta have a hopper for the new
stuff let's do it as you can tell I'm
very low rank because again I didn't
play myself outside for that first week
of launch and my weapons are probably
all garbage let's find everyone use the
shotgun for like the first four weeks
you're fine okay cool cool I have one of
those yeah yeah
Brannen Hernandez asks is there gonna be
community Fridays this week
there should be yeah apologies there
wasn't one last week I was knee-deep in
some final fantasy coverage check out no
you can go check out over at GameSpot
calm or youtube.com/ you should
definitely watch that review it is a
doozy so youyou did the editing on that
Tim did the the script and the actual
review but all came together really well
and I've actually watched that review
maybe like seven or eight times now
thank you yeah all right
p90 and rifle stuffer we're having
people say I always love a p90 because
it's just bulldoze okay I could I could
I could start messing with some stuff I
didn't play long enough to really find
my like weapon groove so I'm always down
to take suggestions yeah I usually fall
back into submachine guns for some
reason which I think it's because in the
old games used to be able to do wield
them and I don't know probably something
tells you just gauges emphasis on
realism does not let you do wheels but
maybe I'm wrong but I loved like in
black ops just using like dual scorpions
and whipping around corners and dolphin
diving through windows yeah that was
peak Call of Duty for me p90 and a rifle
is what mentals been talking about being
a jam and then a rifle that's my second
you see right
give me one sec Diego Rojas says my
loneliness is killing me my responses
and I and Fame must confess I still
believe I hope that was a setup for that
see how that goes see if I miss the
reward from season one - there gonna be
a way to go back and get those T rewards
again I don't think so
it works like other passes though I'm
not a hundred percent sure so don't
float me on it yeah that's so that's a
good question I was actually curious
about that myself
yeah I know how I died
okay well I definitely a scope on this
thing but let's see how it goes hello
whoa ah fantastic game still having
crumbs I'm I'm curious to drop into this
and see where this game is at cuz it's
did a whole bunch of stuff called video
and really Dumbledore cross-play is a
big one that I'm curious how it's
affecting you yeah I mean it seems like
there's just like a lot of in didn't
I've noticed that this seems like the
Call of Duty that's the tableau hello
that guy should have killed me that has
way more interest around it like
post-launch
than previous call goons in like a wild
look what maybe it's like the content
plan to just give everything to everyone
for free or yeah some like the content
plan the way they're kind of pimping out
their seasons I just see a lot like a
lot more buzz around this game also real
talk when did season to happen I
remember it launching in there they
brought goes back yeah but it was so
fast it feels like it was just weeks ago
time has no meaning anymore it's true
time is just a suggestion exams
p90 is nice I dig it
good seems unfair yeah games a service
or cut it's starting to kind of be a
thing I don't like it's it's wearing on
me lost that prevented joined in
progress
okay well it's nice I guess yeah it's
the thing where the girl every game is
asking me to devote all my time and it's
like weird I don't know it's it's weird
to be like that too because at one point
I remember when everything started to
shift that we were like ah never ending
content I'll be able to come back to
Call of Duty every like week and have
something completely new to do and now
it's just every game there's like two
different styles of it there's like
there's there
like every game does it like Call of
Duty does it in like you know destiny in
all these games and it becomes this
thing of life to pick which one I really
wanted to vote my time to but then you
have weird cases where there are games
that try and implement things like that
in a game that doesn't make sense like
the Fez does really far crimes made most
recent games I'll do you one leader doom
eternal has a battle to determine I was
like a battle pass and there's no reason
for it
yeah it's like there's there's literally
a season of things to unlock and doom
eternal yeah and you're like why it's
it's a single-player game it's got a
multiplayer mode but like that
multiplayer mode is fun but not
something that I'm gonna be like coming
back to constantly like it's a really
weird thing to include like a game like
destiny or game like Call of Duty it
makes sense right the games built around
it and it makes sense you have a pass
because it it's a part of the gameplay
like hook doom is like if I want to reap
I don't need a battle pass to
incentivize like hey make sure to come
back weekly for your weekly dailies it's
like I don't need that to be an
incentive to play doom again I'll play
doom again because I really just want to
play doom again I I don't know if I want
to play do with hurtle you go find doom
2016 together I'm still at that point
but that's that's fair I personally will
play I will probably play both again at
some point because I really like both
games but I'm not gonna
I like ample I will never ever think to
myself boy I really just want to check
in and get those battle pass points for
doom eternal some people ask me what
mode this is this is the the kind of
like the mosh pit hog yeah all of the
new maps that's the season 3 mod I don't
think you were in a new map uh in that
last match I'd yeah I was gonna say I'm
pretty sure that map was in what's in it
launch so that's kind of weird this is a
new map though this is one of the Call
of Duty the original mono marker Maps
but they put back in I believe
complaining about stuff to do in the
game even though it's like no I mean
we're talking about how they kind of
like games of service stuff has made it
into games that don't necessarily mean
yeah
we're saying is like cartlett duty makes
total sense this game just kind of built
around it game like do maternal like
does anyone care about that the fact
that game as a battle pass like it's not
bad I don't think it like hurts the game
because it doesn't affect the game at
all it but it's just weird that is in
there it's very strange
yeah but you want talk about something
positive as I'm still got Final Fantasy
7 on the brain so stoked to play oh but
I'm sure that again bringing up a thing
that definitely has a good crossover
with right there spiky-haired it does
slot my materia into my p90 really okay
what I lose the perk system other than
the materia system then I'd play that
I'm not you know if you were to tell me
like materia but you put it in guns I'd
be like I'm sold yeah gun materia isn't
that just what a ballerina is or
whatever yeah I guess I just I still
think the best thing is shower run as a
comparison for that oh sure it's like a
balance shadow run I like shadow run -
I've only gotten to play a little bit
so we've got 60 seconds I'm almost in
nice one of the new modern warfare 2
maps come to the new modern warfare I
think this is it I think yeah it ate
them went together is it opposed to be
this should be one of the new maps I
believe I think it is about one of the
new maps I mean it's an old modern
warfare map new maps old maps or new
maps
once again when they come around oh you
know what I also just realized what I am
on the ps4 that's okay we can play
together yeah so I'm gonna need to add
John our separate thing okay that's cool
the Activision account or whatever it is
yeah we I can do that once I get it I'll
probably get in before you finish this
match yeah we can do that yeah right
that's what I'm saying love it just kind
of like popped up out of nowhere it was
this and what else got like a date today
just terrible
Final Fantasy 14 got a big update it's a
lot of updates happening this week those
are one of the things he recommend would
be play and I was like man I'm level due
at 10:00 there was a point where I was
like you know joking wise there are two
things that I can actually like
recommend imagine if we actually went
through with the Yaak isn't the guy cool
I saw I saw somebody on Twitter a ray
from you he said we're headed sheep in
Hunter he streams I think I don't know
if you know him yeah he was tweet about
how he's really enjoying Yakuza zero and
that he's glad he gave the game another
chance specifically because it was on
Xbox game pass have a good time and I'm
like it works the system works it's
there it's all together
Crabbie's all right I'm load name making
it up I'll take it
I'm saying requires restarted sure yeah
I will valorem to ps4 if I knew I'd tell
you that's just a beta so I mean is who
knows you can't really can't really say
much that game is like pretty early on
oh my beard is looking good thanks it's
my my my hardcore Quarantine beard I've
I've been enjoying seeing everyone's
different Quarantine beards tomorrow's
got a real real good beard going right
now
it's it's just kind of like it's wild
how not you know like you need to like
take care of it's the great thing out
not taking care of my beards it almost
takes care of itself like it looks
better than if I try to take care of it
I've been there for sure oh wait a
minute why did he call him Simon whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa ghost
is ghost does not ghosts who's ghost in
this are you watching like did the intro
trailer at plays yeah who is ghost in
this so ghost is not it's a new goes
it's a ghost
but it yeah literally the first line is
just like a weird low realization for me
and I don't know what to think any
remember how ghosts into was the same
voice as gas and everyone was convinced
it was gas dango saw that mine too late
this move number there's quarantine
beard it's true
oh yeah what
oh no that's what it's telling me I can
shoot
all right oh dang
we need to
add friends
interactive fish okay yeah yeah
Activision account that's good how's
chatter males like which buttons prone
again my dad or deep did you happen no
your activation ID offhand no it's like
a bunch of numbers and yeah it's weird
I can try searching on PC just for your
name there maybe maybe what I can I can
just it's just your your battlenet right
I think so
yeah if you got my battle in the good
for friends on battlenet I might be able
to just do it the boy are we friends up
out on that we got to a play at least
something at some point like I rounded
overwatch or something yeah maybe not
what Oh from behind how I see this
everyone though hekia
all right thank you added me I can do
some some weird sideways stuff for this
second I could probably find you through
friends of friends okay if you're still
playing honey you said you won yeah I
just won
so here I'll leave lobby if you want
here I'll go to my camp for a sec so I
keep my friends list away I can just
tell you the to add me okay I shot down
that's just just it's just philanthropy
looks like I find my mind Activision
yeah I can search using battlenet well
I'm on PlayStation I have to do that
here I can search using PlayStation so
that should just be philanthropy but
with install suspended for cut you out
of here never mind I'm I can't do anyway
because the it's not actually done
updating it oh you can't know it there's
stuff dating but it's got more updates
to do here do you just want to message
me or your PlayStation ID yeah one site
I think my act
Activision one is just philanthropy no
and it's easier to spell okay if you
want to try it with the zero
is I hate and that's it no numbers or
anything just with the zero that's it
okay there it is yeah except ah perfect
like I'm not even logged in yet I saw it
there we go okay
my dailies 25 kills with your secondary
weapon why is it why is it doing this
you okay shirt download your things
let's put that on yeah that's fine
I I don't know what's happening but I
think there's a whole bunch more stuff
that I have to download excellent
I can play war zone okay but I can't
play multiplayer that's okay I'll just
keep multiplayer on my own but we should
try war zone as well because they've
also updated that I believe yeah what is
this ah yeah it's okay it's just a whole
other like 30 gigs it has to download
I'm really excited to not be in this
Call of Duty one the new one
alright cool
I'll just wait on the menu then well
that goes
[Music]
you got to download literally every
excellent I'm still surprised that the
initial like 40 gig update wasn't
everything I surprisingly didn't have
that much to download I don't know if I
just I'm not sure why they like had
already download in the background but
it was actually a really quick quick
download for me it's the the other thing
too is everything's broken up into packs
okay this is not one of the new map I
don't know why you have to find specific
packs to download on top of the update
weird it didn't do that for me at all at
least cuz it's the PlayStation Network
oh right your yeah cuz you're doing it
for PlayStation I'm doing through PC
yeah explain it play Minecraft I you
wouldn't want to watch me play Minecraft
I'm not very good at it unless you like
just watching people dig like underneath
everyone else's stuff they make and then
like blowing it up cuz that's all I do I
was debating a suggesting we just dream
Animal Crossing and I was just gonna
show everyone my sick island no awesome
games see I do have auto update on the
auto update had just finished but then
there are the DLC packs that you have to
download on top of it by telling the
game to do it that were needed for it
it's just like
yeah it doesn't say I'm locked out of
war zone so that's that's all good
oh it's an old map but it's just it's
new because it's a small smaller version
of that's why I reckon
okay I was wondering why this was
showing up in the hopper yea-ah whoever
suggested this gun good recommendation
do p90 is always good gun to to lean on
it's a classic it's got like 90 bullets
inside of its magazine that's that's
wild so many bullets as opinion Alex
coming back do you think he's needed for
I need to be more battle-scarred
or just the leg is enough uh I'm not
surprised that they brought him back
because they're like ah here's ghost
here's Alex here's just keep it's not a
canonical thing I assumed that was just
like I think it's just whatever the lair
and I assumed he was still like sorry
spoilers dead in the campaign I think he
is also the the realization with ghost
is a weird thing because yeah I can't
tell if this is all supposed to be like
canonical or not cuz I'm pretty sure
ghosts isn't that wasn't his name it was
didn't have a name in modern warfare 2
unless I'm missing remember I'm pretty
sure was just ghost
well I mean his name is Simon Riley yeah
in modern warfare 2 in just in what he
is they like his Israel name is Simon
Riley so weird name
mm-hmm yeah I don't think it's like they
actually brought them back brought them
back I think it is right but it's weird
because they have these like cutscenes
and this like narrative so like they're
obviously trying to do some sort of
narrative element to the seasons but
then I don't it sound like is that
supposed to be its own thing is it
supposed to be within the fiction of the
campaign so I think they might be trying
to do what blackops was doing with their
stuff which was kind of more interesting
because they didn't really like do a lot
with it but there's there's something
there for sure they're definitely trying
to do something
a p90 with the suppressor and a tach
laser is good yeah because you don't
even have to like a method you just kind
of like whip around and you know where
you're at it sounds pretty good
yeah you should be able to do a wheeled
p90s in this you should again I think
it's just that they're going for that
more realistic tone yeah oh I want that
guys want more bad companies I want more
silly games me too what if we just
played bad company to doom I'm here I'm
there let's do that for Friday there you
go everyone and solve your dad company
twos
do a heck yeah we're getting in a golf
cart and in driving all over though I
love that company two big same so it's
kind of excited when they were like
they're kind of hinting that battlefield
5 might have kind of been it wasn't yeah
I kind of hit this weird middle ground
where I feel like I heard like I'm still
doing alright I'm sure it's got its
audience but it just didn't growl me the
way I wanted to - yeah there's a lot of
cool stuff for sure
I mean I miss just heaven I was
definitely more of like I played a ton
of Call of Duty but I was definitely
more
it's just look I gotta have my vehicles
and I gotta have my open I think what I
like about this is it's more
opportunities for silliness like you're
talking about like hey we're gonna put
everybody on the wings of this plane and
then fly overhead and everyone's gonna
jump off or we're gonna attach c-4 to
this vehicle like that kind of stuff
yeah especially with that company too
and that that uh that LEvolution
nonsense
no LEvolution was a what they call them
for three and four kind of mixed
together for me but i think you can do
wheeled pistols in this game but i don't
think you can do wield a lot of
submachine guns vodka maybe you can do
wield the p90 oh I knew that I knew
there is a guy there but I got the
thanks I'm good got that thing I got
that thing
heck yeah no but if we what if we played
the the Godzilla game on ps4 this Friday
what's a Godzilla game oh yeah oh yeah
it's not good but I can play as Jet
Jaguar that's enough to seal the deal
for me apasa apparently it's also a hard
game to find now physically as people
are charging like 200 250 dollars for
the most recent bet yeah the most recent
battlefield had the battle royale mode
which it was okay I never tried that's
kind of I never tried it was it was the
most kind of vanilla battle royale I
think I've played I don't remember
anyone talking about it I think Michael
played it a bit cuz he had to do like
the review ration things he reviewed
five you like that game everybody he
digged it no Godzilla game was ever good
destroy all monsters melee was pretty
good mm but it's it is kind of difficult
to find a good license also Godzilla
games are a hard thing for them to get
together cuz each character has its own
license oh that makes sense
yeah sort of like sort of like songs and
rock band you have to get separate
licenses for each monster and I'm
Godzilla game destroy all monsters melee
was really good because it was more of
an arcade game and it was a four player
fighting deal but the best thing I can
say about the one on ps4 is it really
captures the feeling of controlling us
sweaty man inside of a rubber suit
because that's exactly how it controls
that's pretty good but it is just kind
of cool to to see the monsters
and like a current gen game doing a
thing
she watched any Godzilla films oh yes a
lot when I was a kid I actually just
recently ordered a blu-ray copy of Shing
Godzilla and I'm very excited to watch
that Godzilla films were a thing that my
my dad was like you need to watch these
cuz they're good and I only like the
parts where the monsters were on the
screen which was only like 30% of them
yeah until was Godzilla
are you in yet or if you're playing I
can play war zone I can't okay it's it's
I'm gonna be locked out pretty much the
whole rest of the stream for multiplayer
okay well I can use like one or two more
matches then we can switch to war zone
if you want okay
streams are the bomb heck yeah I'm glad
that you're having a great time but yeah
but he's like having a fun characters
Jet Jaguar by a longshot
I love that man dead to the same thing
see you know then you know the
experience is that Congress Godzilla
coming out I have no idea I be into it
so it was maybe in a weird kind of
roundabout way the best Godzilla game
might have been or the monsters even
though it wasn't a Godzilla game I
thought you were gonna say that um
dreams level we played Oh dreams office
really good ones dream so you please
like a like an axolotl
encourage you and it's just adorable
adorable and destructive I love it Kong
and wreck Godzilla pretty pretty close
fight oh you know there's there's the
whole breath thing and Godzilla can can
scoot on the tail is that movie still
happening I hope I know that they were
working on that
oh that guy's dad Modern Warfare 2
remastered multiplayer coming soon in a
beta that means did they say that are
such a star I haven't seen new people
saying ok that sounds awesome yeah I
hope so cuz I'll play it as well I'd be
the thing to go in double kill
thoughts aren't predator hunting grounds
and play that many matches but like
asymmetrical multiplayer games and that
was a pretty fun one it was still a beta
and there are obviously issues but I'm
sure they could probably work on him
this time goes whoa yeah SP 9 teased oh
yeah dude SMG life is is where it's at
you just shoot so many shots down like
so quickly it's it's best although I am
almost out of ammo that's the downside
of putting down so much ammo so fast is
that you run out of ammo that's not it
oh you go I literally just unlocked a
munitions box
rampage counters Godzilla game those
weren't terrible I know I enjoyed
rampage
most of my experience with it is playing
it inside of like a like a pizza place
when I was a kid mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
everyone like a like a game boy at one
point that was pretty cool better than
IGN we try to do our best but there are
a lot of good people over there too but
we appreciate that you you enjoy us yeah
I'm just still like I love kind of going
in and watching a lot of their videos so
they used to work there and seeing some
of my friends like do like doing videos
are there the whole like doing videos on
your house it's fun yeah it's wacky like
charm to it it's it's interesting to see
like ah the news videos that they used
to do now they have people on like
conference calls like next to each other
doing news instead of having it's it's
wild she watched the recent Godzilla
films that's why I was I I got shin
Godzilla coming in this weekend so I'm
looking forward to watch I haven't seen
Godzilla but I've heard so many good
things about it that's what I'm saying
I've been hearing a lot of good things
and they put the blu-ray up for like
five bucks I was like really tempted to
pick up that criterion collection I was
like the Godzilla's for like it was like
two or three decades ago of the first
like ten Godzilla's or something like
that that's the other thing too it's so
hard to find Godzilla movies like it's
almost impossible to find them on
blu-ray
right so like it's I still do want to
get the part it's just um yeah it was
just a lot of a lot of money to commit
to although I do think they'd sell them
separately at least they did so you
could you could just get the ones who
wanted it's true I just want I just want
Godzilla versus Megalon brought up into
into 4k that's my favorite one
yeah I hope they do the rest of them
because I didn't do them all no I I grew
up watching those as a kid yeah we
should watch some soup when all this is
over we go back to so the office we
should watch some Godzilla films and the
speeds oh you know Kurt would be down
with that Kurt loves Godzilla oh hell
yeah
the current Kurt's one of the best
people oh yeah Kurt I one of the the top
things that I am top 10 things that I
miss from working in the offices and
seen Kurt a high five from Kurt every
day at 5 o'clock when he gets ready to
leave for anyone doesn't doesn't know
almost every day in the office when Kurt
is ready to leave at either 5 or 6 he
gets up and he walks around me
high-fives everyone and it's like a
really good way to kind of like
decompress you know the day is coming to
an end it's it's real nice
and speaking of Kurt if you haven't
watched the video on the basement song
and the Resident Evil DualShock version
on PlayStation you should definitely
watch that was a nice surprise I didn't
know he was working on that they were
doing on that topic and I have always
had a hilarious like fascination with
that track so to find out that Kurt did
a video on it I was like oh that's
excellent yeah I actually like I didn't
know anything about oh I love Resident
Evil and I was surprised I didn't know
about this man who tricked people for 20
years that he was deaf and composing
music yeah that's why yeah I like knew
about the song and then I had heard
about the composer being a scam when
that came out but I didn't know that
those two
connected and then I found that out like
a little while later I was like oh
that's the same what that's good net so
it's a really good video I highly
recommend it
very good time I know every day at 5 or
6 o'clock you either got to do an
imaginary high-fived occurred or
high-five yourself it's true probably
you can do Y fives like face the same
direction and kind of like spiritually
do it spiritually yeah it's the small
things yeah you think about its true oh
wow Oh mr. predator to be able to take
out Godzilla what do you make a list of
things that could take out Godzilla can
i play with you oh not not today just
cuz we're we're kind of just going
through what they going through the city
I did but if you do want to play with us
every Friday John Luke and I host a show
where we play games with you expressly
that's that's the whole point that we
kind of rotate out through whatever is
happening fighting games first-person
shooters whatever and we try to play it
with you guys last week we were gonna do
PSO but then a whole bunch of embargo
stuff came up for making sure Final
Fantasy 7 was what this week this week
is different we're gonna we're gonna be
here and we're gonna play a video game
with you guys something something we're
not sure yet but it'll be something
have I thanked you for 17 in a
forty-sevens hey I won them Oh Matt's
online he's playing boo
whoo all right you want to uh go Franco
so you can visit
uh yeah be down when we do animal
crossing we usually just open it up with
a dodo code yeah and do it that way but
I went in it's uh it's really funny
because then everyone's just yep just be
Tori such a good game heck yeah I
haven't played the new one but here a
lot of people say they really liked it
all right so I'm logged in you want to
join my my squad I can do just that I
mean this social oh yeah there's there's
Matt right there and there you also try
inviting Matt blammo as well no it's all
just join him if you want to I just
tried to invite him i curious if you'll
show her my squad okay so we'd I mean we
what's the new mode in this four player
four player it's just that's it okay
let's do it yeah and then they have guns
that cross over into everything okay
think
your boy is not a call of duty man I
have to get through like 16 ads of them
telling me to buy the season pass by the
new buy the thing okay we breathe your
animation weird I didn't know this was
the thing it's just like an animation of
this gun hey Mitch sometimes you just
got to watch gun animations but it's not
even doing anything I thought was gonna
like fire that's that's too much all
right
okay this is where I revealed that this
is actually my first time ever playing
this mode so that's fine if if you
played a battle royale it's like that
except it takes way longer than most
other battle Royales to finish school
here wontak talking in the microphone
well I guess we're dropping spicy I'm
not even loaded in yet oh well yeah I'm
going over here no this is just the okay
it's way just to the lobby okay cool I
was like oh my Tama gun she's dead it's
the safe distance I can draw from not
that oh well I guess
okay
oh man I keep messing up this parachute
drop
this little longest pregame thing I've
been in for this it's game time warm-ups
done let's do it man just think they
filmed battle royale and you'll be fine
there you go ah here we are ready to
jump out where we were sleeping where we
dropping weave I was trying not to ask
like where we dropping boys but it looks
like farmlands we're thinking no I'll
get four lines fun I did it I said copy
that on it confirmed I'm ready to go
all right
she will still play battlegrounds I'm
sure people do their there unlike a
fifth season or whatever but it's not
it's not something I play now got this
parachute I deploy my parachute way too
early
okay I'm gonna run over to you I think
being in in pairs is probably the best
way to do this yeah okay I can't keep
everything all together always I do not
have any armor big same it's a gun there
Lou hello
definitely take that yeah you go ahead
and take that here we go a little bit
armor ready I feel like I apply it don't
you oh yeah you got really hold on
triangle I think it's been a while so
favorite things about season three so
far um I like that they're just
continually putting out content for the
game for free that's really nice I don't
know there's anything like one thing in
particular about this that's like like
stands that was like oh [ __ ] but it's
more like okay they're just continually
adding stuff and it's kind of nice to
hop in here and see any stuff yeah whoa
this this guy just took my gun can't
believe this I probably want this took
my gun now he's thinking about dropping
it I don't know what guns are good in
this I was winging it there's a silenced
pistol over there if anyone's interested
this game worth it
I'd say this is worth it cuz it's free I
mean I have words that you can just play
for free if you want if if you're
looking for a cool free battle royale to
play with your pals and you've got like
80 gigs of free space you should
definitely download and you're not
already playing apex that's another one
- I've got a heartbeat sensor now so
that's good things cool all right I
forgot the you know when heartbeat
sensors were in modern warfare 2 yeah
man we were playing that campaign last
yeah you remember when Bad Company 2
took a stab directly at heartbeat
sensors yes I did the campaign you do
because you also mentioned I am this two
months cool shoot I don't even remember
tank you like tell me about it I mean
you can say it again it is really funny
it's a good time helping choose good
people should play it
should we just wait or should we move
forward we're kind of like right on the
edge I'm good to kind of move forward
myself a little bit yeah like it's
always good to just stay ahead
everything it's no point in standing
still for not really doing anything
about sitting so once a lost yeah I
think we lost been everyone my poor cat
are you there I didn't even know he
wasn't yeah yeah I didn't know my cat
was in here and he's just like hey
what's up let me out of your room
I lost her webcam and everything oh
there's a guy here yeah it took it down
I have a laser gun you have a laser gun
and I have a World War 2 rifle dang it
got him I got one yeah yeah yeah
sweet what about her I know where that
guy went whoa that gun oh wait he's this
guy's dead too well III got one if you
got one and I got one then we got both
oh that's what was you killed the other
guy and then they both dropped nice okay
cool
we're in this unfortunately other two
guys died that's fair and it happens mr.
fender I don't mean that do you want
some armor plate yeah by station that
was hold on that was the stupidest thing
I've ever done
and one more that man that takes a
really long time to do take this okay I
don't have that much money damn it
here's some money though now I have
money
oh wait we can redeploy people I was
right here give us very station I did it
I bought her friend back
nice let's get him back in here it's on
the way
I just managed to pick up like just
enough money to do it and then we should
probably head like over here I mean we
should probably maybe go further
probably like there yeah I'm I'm down
let's give him a sec to get a [ __ ]
that's a custom pistol yeah I've got a
laser gun um I didn't realize that they
had that in this okay let's do it yeah
see like like what home looking footing
this see that is it please yes all this
is just green tracer I might just
because it just sounded like a bullets
to me I didn't see any lasers hollowed
out drop over that do we want to go for
that
I think it's cuz someone called it in so
there's people that there's a car here
though do you want take the car I'm down
what's the drive probably not me
alright he's driving it looks like he's
driving take us there pal he didn't want
to do it it's okay I got it
alright you drive I'm the wheelman it's
my turn to go okay so that area is right
on the edge maybe we should instead go
here
oh man will the drainage ditch this
thing's got like some sort of like feral
scope
thank you
well the money on the trash can are you
blind I got time for the money on the
trash can also I didn't see money on the
trash can there was money on trash can I
grabbed a minute ago the distri might be
very power bond if that's the case oh
that could be it unless there was
different money on different trash can
they're referring to it's all all
possibility get rid of that don't stop
marking things okay so we've got bunkers
that's cool doesn't seem like anyone's
uh whoa car car car car car car I was
just gonna let him drive away but sure
okay sneaked up a contract now you want
to do it I'm down all right let's go for
it let's get these crates
you leave the guy back in the car you
guys take the car all scope ow
it sounds like a plan see you there this
guy's way over there do this scope is
broken oh yeah I remember people saying
that thermals were just really good yeah
yeah just I can just be like no this guy
just way over there is this like a like
I shouldn't be in the car kind of thing
or like no they're really far away I'm
just kind of letting you know we're
there oh I see him
yeah never mind I'm gonna keep doing oh
these guys are new I mean yeah haven't
really played much of it now this is my
first time playing this mode okay it's
John Luke's first time playing looks to
be empty I'm going for it
yeah which makes me nervous Alex carpet
sensors like my favorite thing
oh you're you're wrapped all the way
around your Geordie up ahead you Hawkin
just oh yeah just scare everyone cool
wait yeah there we go
that's a shotgun drive this through you
don't want to roll in our cool blue car
yeah that's probably it it now
I'm just gonna start driving so we know
or do we want to try to get that uh yeah
that's probably yeah
I found the handbrake button are we just
waiting
I could probably oh no we got her our
teammate back that's what it was sick so
so let's hold up here for a second way
for him to drop in
I appreciate that he waited yeah yeah
her nein nein t8 it's only good with a
scope I've seen some people do some
pretty cool things without a scope for
it
oh yeah I mean I killed that guy earlier
without scope but I would like a scope
for it that's true I don't even know you
had a kernel yay yeah heck yeah that's
what I kill that guy with earlier
circles closing in now we got it we got
a move are we moving moving
think so we just waiting on the last guy
yeah I think he's dropping in there is
alright everyone's in
I'm just gonna drive along the line
oh right there now right this isn't even
bad
now perfect nailed it oh we're getting
shot at right get some shots happening
we're okay click to the Russian burger
town do a hole up there I'm down no no
we probably shouldn't okay and I was
ready for it I don't know where a good
place to hole up is someone market thing
back there let's let's go for this
that's definitely not abandon airbase
okay because there's a jump that's
pretty good by the way I might be the
worst person to ever play battle Royales
that's okay
no man dude every time I play battle
rails up reals with you I've had a great
time heck yeah however this spot
maybe the spot is a little dangerous oh
this seems like a good place to use that
thermoscope oh no it does it does indeed
being tracked
oh no that's this is gone bad air
striking coming this is the worst place
to stop up what if we got in the car and
made a run for it
oh I was like oh wow what my teammates
are sitting over here in the corner oh I
forgot about the Gulag of course
yeah I do like that some of you guys in
the chanter are getting parties together
that's really good
oh that's awesome so we man at least I
didn't let him make it
sorry I'll buy you back in you're still
alive I'm in the gulag so I'm about to
about to choke this Bank in do it
I believe in you man oh look I I know I
saw the hit marker I hit him square in
the body that's fine did hit him come on
do one more yeah
I'm in
I like this but man am I not great how
do you quit out of the so I think you
just say leave game that's that yeah and
it should take me with you know bad for
you for some plain there you go thank
you I would have lasted longer if I
hadn't been like oh shoot there's a jump
here let me hit it you're all good deed
I love it though oh there's a skill
track watch that I okay let's do it
again
my mind the party still yeah sue it I
think some wheat yeah yeah your your
ghost right I'm the ghost if you're all
the stuff that I haven't looked at in my
my inventory should probably go through
it some 15 piles of cash from the ground
that's a that's a mission I can do
so showing a hundred gigabytes for the
update I know it's only twelve what
should I do
mine was 40 and then I had 30 gigs on
top that I had to do separately so
update sir are a lot in Call of Duty
servers down for anyone else servers
aren't done for us cuz we're still
playing yeah we're doing good it is
getting to be about that time over on
the East Coast though where people might
be stopping working and maybe getting on
so maybe there's some weird latency or
connection stuff Oh weren't even
practicing with this one we're just
going right in it's just us I think it's
just us um game you promised me you
promised me quads hey you know we're
just this isn't gonna go well we're
gonna hear disadvantage no this is fine
less people for them to find and kill
ready want to go just move silently as a
team
I'm good with wherever airports always
an exciting place sheriff if our last
once it's anything to go all right
all right I'm going for the red building
there's the big one yeah I'm right
behind you oh this guy right below us
I've landed the Eagles landed it's me
I'm know and I immediately got shot so
Jesse just got a real spicy you know I'm
coming for you and oh you're over on the
other side
I've already been gue logged no that's a
guy see if I can do it it's not will
just hold us Clara
Wow where's the murderer god
hey somehow one that I missed every shot
and then you may lead him anyway I'm
coming back for you sweet how you
holding up
I tried to rush this guy to get revenge
so now I've got to go to the gulag and
not choke alright well I went a little
further away so I can get myself more of
a chance sounds like a good plan okay
silence so carnival enjoy the the random
videos I haven't seen a people like
accidentally setting off landmines with
throwing rocks in the gulag that's more
like banking them off of walls and then
hitting people in the head with them and
killing them like that's that's the good
stuff
[Applause]
just banning to kill this guy I'm
definitely not gonna make it oh I made
it back I throw a Molotov right at a
guys yeah let's come on back down man
I'm here for it all right I'm coming
down I landed on the roof
cuz I'm a dummy no worries there's a car
down here you can grab if you want oh
yeah oh you meant like it like a car
like a German rifle not a car like an
anomaly yeah but we should find one of
those - this is a helicopter I'll go try
and say you lose yeah all right man
here alright let's do it
where are we going only you know
wherever the wind takes us there's a
bunch of people shooting at us because
they're jealous they are go to this IKEA
nice here's a cool let's super than he
is let's go to some like outside let's
go to the quarry do you wanna I already
got you thanks dude so we got this
helicopter now we can we can adventure
around we've got the means oh they got a
helicopter over there too though let's
take their helicopter out alright a
helicopter fight only got five shots
what this have got to make them count
forty waste three they're smoking we can
do it
please tell me they're turning around
isn't to see us they're not turning
around to see us
let's get ramming speed going like bring
me closer over jumped out
okay this is a terrible idea
yeah I'm waiting for the one of them to
have like a rocket launcher which is why
they jumped out goal and at this
hospital
alright seems like a good normal place
to land
who's this right shield that's a good
time hmm it's a right shield because
then it's on your butt yeah that's what
you want
protect that back yeah these some money
there's two helicopters there's another
one over on the other side yeah we can
already there we can make our own
helicopter squad dang I like it there's
a huge map yeah it's it's really really
big
I can always set up a burger town it's
true I bet they've got some sweet loot
at the burger town all right here let's
drop this contract well then we both
grab our helicopters and head out yeah
let's do it I gotta get back upstairs
yeah when you Swan take this one
together should we both accept it
here-take took me over to the other one
and then I'll know I see ya
oh I hit the wrong button you're okay oh
I hit the Ragman that kind of that kind
of wrong button I gotcha
I feel yeah okay cool cool so anyway
we're taking one helicopter these are
the plan man it's called duty y'all love
it
well that's building
ah whoops
hold on hold on I'm getting out
that's dangerous blow up they'll never
suspect us here please my body never
mind this is going really well
dude stop moving around look I can't I'm
sorry I got excited I was looking for
you I shouldn't I shouldn't have looked
for you I knew you knew oh I'm hunted
why am i hunted I even killed anyone I
haven't done anything except put my toes
down I'm gonna buy this armor plate
bundle it's probably good idea and we
should whoa oh geez I'm in a menu that
was the worst right it's cuz something
hard I'm dead dead well that was that
happened yeah yeah that was a real
roller coaster ride and I'm here for it
I'd like to have killed somebody
alright let's uh let's try another one
I'd also like to get a lot of people for
once yeah it's weird that we signed up
for quads and then it didn't give us
quads can grab something to play my
first match what okay you've done it
everything's like a mission behind
oh dang my order with shin Godzilla
blu-ray is actually getting here a day
early I feel that [ __ ] out yeah I'm very
excited yeah that ending probably
wouldn't a lot better if I hadn't blown
up our helicopter on top of the point
mm-hmm
there's a lot there's a lot of there's a
lot of things that yeah you could do a
whole study on on what we went through a
lot of factors at play I agree what's
for lunch today
we're almost we're coming up on middle a
noon time it's almost time for for
dinner
mm-hmm I I don't know it's a good
question I actually haven't eaten yet so
I'll have to see what's going on maybe
I'll make like mac and cheese or some
she kicker wrong with mac and cheese
oh we're done of its stockpile of all
right do you mac and cheese is always a
good time true you can never really go
wrong with it it's a it's one of my
favorite foods it doesn't pretend to be
something it's not
[Music]
how much does it cost to skip hundred
tears I have no idea Oh God
who knows more than I'd be willing to
pay probably wait 152 that's a lot of
people uh I'm ready ready
all right here we are
this is it this is the one you feel it I
feel it oh I'm feeling it man let's do
it yeah yeah I'm the squad leader
without passing that off to Bend two
people have already called out lumber
some guessing that might be the call all
right let's do it yeah it's weird that
they both said it like right away
maybe there's something they know that
we don't
all right
picked his nose rubbed it in this beard
nah man
you don't want to do that to your beard
or someone right next to us
yeah people I'm being shot at I got one
of them I'll Ben come help me
Oh bind you behind you behind you behind
you bind you
oh oh wait for me this it's nothing I
could do
I didn't realize that her other person
had me dropped in yeah man that was a
wild place is just kind of go in to drop
spicy yeah yeah some fights I everytime
I always forget that I've got a second
chance with the Gulag I was like man I
can't believe we're already out I got
him nine I'm back I'm not back I'm out
out oh no a guy lasered me right in the
head
well everyone else is dead so I'm just
gonna go find myself a quick yeah sounds
like a plan
live mas
hey I got one guy whoa and I'm dead
hey you found what you're looking for
because you're white you wanted to try
to get another one there I did find out
ready three dudes that's a lot that's a
lot all what the other guy came back we
should we see how he does is up to you
down either way he's got a big gun
I'll give him a minute we'll see if he
does anything I think exciting yeah
crazy cool he's running the opposite way
of the people who got you though it is
it's probably smart all right dude
Brandon's calling for you to show off
your your animal crossing island just
last minute switch on the stream just
switch it on over yeah
we we could probably we could probably
yeah let's just leave so I think all
right it's for the sake of getting like
one more quick jump in you know yeah
dovabear that first batch was their best
one though as usually okay oh yeah this
this is war zone there is regular
multiplayer outside of this yeah we're
playing that earlier but your boy had 40
gigs of updates to download so all I can
do is war zone so I pulled John Luke
away from it
cuz Call of Duty it's called Judy's it's
too big it's it's it's too much
uh-uh have either of us gotten first in
this before so you haven't cuz this is
all that you've played of it I won one
game like the day it came out because no
one knew what they were doing and then I
kind of was like cool now I've seen the
peak of this I didn't do any more of it
I'll kind of sniper right hello
I mean - lets practice and shooting that
guy Dan there we go yeah we're stuff
happened during stream I know that goes
fortunately I haven't had too much pop
up meal thing
all right let's do it ray
where are we going I'm down to go to the
quarry on the outside edge because
that's also where all the people who are
afk are gonna drop sure your try doing
that now let's do it
all right
[Music]
changeup
as soon as I said I didn't have any work
happen my god you got a bunch of beans
it's the PlayStation look like anyone
else dropped her yeah
which is good because that means more
loot for us okay this is good who is all
there's some there's some sweet lag
happening right now yeah I've been
getting a little bit of that I am
rubber-banding all over this room right
now
okay have you sought rifle alright uh
how you doing on equipment I'm doing not
bad not bad at all
here shots I heard that as well
ooh I'll definitely take that c4 sounds
like a good time I'm up doing bad at all
sick sudden maybe pick up some more ammo
I'd be sad I'm pretty good Oh even
better
I got that I got that thermal scope
again Hank yeah oh I've got a thermal
scope on my submachine gun it was good
for like picking things off but what
should we you have the same gun yeah
yeah Parabellum yeah yeah yeah yeah dude
heck yeah all right let's uh I guess
move forward goat truck over here that
we can get in I got that contract near
us that would probably be a good call
yeah uh little you guys or purchase
stream tomorrow
not sure sure whoa legendary sniper heck
yeah look forward to me missing every
shot re good news I've got the truck
[Applause]
there is a guy in here apparently though
oh really yeah I got a bounty to kill a
guy oh where the marker is a sense
I'm wiki parking my Hornet scary
see upstairs I think says he's still
here he has moved
weird and the something else is going on
well one of our guys is down gonna get
in the truck and save him
yeah yeah well here you get in the truck
I'll run this way story out in the gulag
who's this press you couldn't find that
guy back there for the country yeah I
don't know what do you what that was
that's weird
Oh your gunfire
oh they're shooting at me where from her
there's some like flare or fire shot
that happens he just got in the truck I
just saw that what like a ghost out of
nowhere he's gone now he just
disappeared from it but I don't know if
this is a connection thing I'm not
really sure what's going on uh I don't
like it very strange oh but you saw it
you saw him get in the car no I saw that
too and I was shooting at him okay all
right cool
well our guys back so I guess that's
cool yeah get him get him get him got
him nice nice Muse's teammate might
still be around but I'm gonna get you
thank you thank you thank you Oh
how long have these guys been here I
don't know but I don't like it come on
I'm gonna take his assault rifle though
I would do it it's got a thermal sight
and it's silence okay we should
definitely get out of here but they call
it a loadout drop on the other side so
we should jump them
I don't know this is just like one in
the world I think yeah okay not there's
just wait there over the left
yeah thermal sights are stupid God first
friends up way over to the side I'm
gonna take that car think unless they're
grabbing they see us see getting shot at
where are they their way down the way
and they're dead I cannot tell what the
drop rate on this gun is at all I'm
obviously not hitting them got one
dang I'm I'm two kills in that guy did
oh there's a sniper right down there
shoot we're now down where it's marked
that one nice
No Deal do we keep the same people from
season two if you earned them you get to
keep them on no here we go ready to
choke again Friday where are they
oh he's running for my loadout Oh rabbit
dude do that thing this game worth
buying yes cuz it's free if you want to
play boy zone war zone is free
yeah so what we're playing right now is
a thing you can download and experience
I've got a couple good downs there's
that so pretty good about that who guys
won the game I hope we hope we at least
get pretty far in this
I've already botched it and definitely
died we'll get you back gonna miss my
cool gun though I think we can get you
right here no all right I can get to the
buy station or no I have enough oh shoot
I hit the thing I think the other guy
has money for ya he's looking over and
checking that direction there is a car
driving away oh if he gets the shot
a helicopter flying overhead is a heck
of a thing - mm-hmm
oh jeez forgot about those support wars
on with new college Ooty comes it'll be
an interesting thing to see if they do
or they don't cuz I feel like if right I
want this to actually stay around they'd
have to but I mean you also look at it's
not an exact similar situation black ops
call of duty is always weird because
they try and integrate these sort of
like you know Conway we talked about the
beginning in the stream the they're like
you know live service model but unlike
other games where they just have the one
game like destiny and fortnight like
Call of Duty's like an annual series so
they kind of try and have it both way
it's sort of weird they're a whole bunch
down at the end of the street
hmm yeah I mean call duty modern warfare
is a pretty good call of duty yeah it's
it's not like my favorite but it's it's
definitely worth worth getting I think
sure it's been discounted now at this
point to probably but again if you want
to just play this bit this is Dan we
need to get you back
are you are you low on ammo me okay okay
I have a thing that actually will drop
ammo
oh nice never gap noise better gasps oh
God I see another guy up there it's
gonna mark that just in case but I know
you guys I think I'm like a hundred
dollars short yeah plus the gas
unfortunately that's not gonna do you
any good good oh he's actually gonna buy
me you know I'll sure don't it's a hot
draw what a champion dang oh yes do it
Oh No my friends going abandon them I
want to go drop on this car over here
oh there's a there's a person here this
is a this is a weird call
all right we're over here
I found a personal on this bridge who's
gonna jump and I've got a friend dropped
in a bad place
Oh bummer just try not to die I'm trying
I'm trying to stay alive right now I'm
I'm in the oh shoot he's here
yeah I got him you got him I did you
pick up his equipment before his friends
come and get who okay
some like Snake Eater garbage that I'm
going through right now and I don't like
it I believe in you dude
Austin's are right over there this
doesn't have a mom I'm coming for you I
don't know what I'll be able to do but
I'm coming to them and say if you shoot
no I shouldn't have stopped to heal I
sure just went for the murder
a waste I wasted that man's harder and
$4,500
we also immediately abandon that man
after he deployed you nope still I'm
just a hundred dollars short actually
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa over there
dang yeah that's my fault I was too busy
looking for money to save you I wasn't
thinking you know what that's fine cuz
we we were ten minutes over Oh what your
hold on you're doing this anyway Africa
my keep your forgot about this keep keep
it going you got it oh well there much
you do not purpose because it we're to
pretend when it's over yeah we just
reflect to our remaining party member
hopefully he pulled it through that was
actually kind of fun fun final one I got
a couple kills which is fun yeah thank
you everybody for joining for this
stream we are 10 minutes over s and said
but yeah if you like this stream make
sure to sup and hit that Bell and all
that nonsense so you can check out more
if you like what you saw me and Ben
normally stream every Friday where we
played games with you guys not sure what
we're playing this Friday we'll have to
have that conversation figure we'll
figure that out otherwise yeah normally
Persia is the one who streams she wasn't
feeling well so wish her the best and
hopefully you'll see her tomorrow
anything else Ben yeah uh please watch
the video reviews for both persona and
final fantasy we gave two tens out which
is true something that we don't ever do
impressive in within two weeks and yeah
sure subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss any of stuff we do all right
thanks watching guys
you